how much are you going to make on that
tour boys
oh yes
let's all just love each other that's it
bro it's Christmas why you hold back
[Music]
knowledge and to take you oh God no
Fitness surprise the Lancers I thought
I'd dress up so I'm just gonna have to
put these on
I mean it's a cheap shitty Sunset did
you knock Santa off the room
when I asked for a Sunday suit I said
the 3x sound they were like I will see
what we can do I think they could have
done better yeah to be honest I've been
getting this belt on was all right sure
if you wear just the trousers you might
look like some sort of WWE character
from the mid 90s I do feel like that
though yeah yeah where's will and
Stephen Hey Stephen will look at this
all right
Merry Christmas
yeah huh you too would actually look
great as a team
now come on or the porno-based podcast
seem to bang
[Music]
welcome back to choose early podcast
Christmas Day episode all the biggest
[__] I could find on YouTube are here
in one room together
thank you cheers
to all the million subscribers and and
the friends brilliant well done Lads
yeah thanks for coming uh me and Alex
were talking last night right hitting a
million subscribers sorry about the
Stevens
thing you can just ever yeah you just do
it and you're like number it was a bit
like that especially for you because I
remember you grinded your bollocks off
not literally but almost to get there uh
you were working like a Japanese
prisoner of war but a happy one it's not
even been a minute yeah
again you want it and then you just like
oh you had the Charisma everyone as well
yeah
drink up
this is gonna be if you're expecting a
good podcast oh you're in for a [__]
show we're just gonna drop off one but
yeah I'll actually watched yours hit a
million dollars I know I got between
unfortunately so I had me heard that I
was going to be the million so I was
like uh you weren't subscribe no no yeah
I refreshed it at like
99.997 and I was like yes and then I
just I was about it and it went to one
million and one of them
you instantly unsubscribed yet like I
literally I was annoyed though because I
had it I wanted to be the guy who like
made you a million subscribers that was
going to be my thing but that's the
funny thing is in in your mind you're
Central to everyone else's story I made
him a million very much like the Jew and
JJ documentary yeah not 100 do you want
to go for a walk on the beach Alex there
is a great moment during the JJ
documentary it's mid fight and it's like
really building up and then it just goes
to the beach and Brian just goes yeah I
love the beach
the funny thing is it was your idea
it was such a good bit though that we
didn't miss it out it goes from this
hits him with one two yeah I love them
it's nice just skimming a stone he was
nature when it comes to hitting a
million
I'm not
I'm not openly annoyed at other people's
success but I guess it's hard not when
you've got a dick look at other people's
dicks do you know what I'm saying and
think do I deserve better do you know
what I'm saying like so there was a
little bit by the time I hit the million
I thought well yeah
like the it's like 100k now
you might actually feel that way it's
not the old 100K it's nothing really
what's she doing when you hit a million
did you have a party or anything no no I
didn't even do that um
video flopped on the day did it yeah my
video flopped on the day I hit it and it
was really annoyed and then I hit it
that's good and then I went to it I was
gonna say
you must have done something I mean to
me it was really weird because of the
fact that because obviously the
challenge the way too well uh I already
got the like feeling of hitting it while
I saw that arrogant yeah
unsubscribe
it projected stats I was like I was
gonna happen now when I was like oh it's
kind of
and obviously keemstar's all told us
that you're just friends with him yeah
so this expose you now you're out it's
only downhill for me yeah just call you
and go was that all right
yeah
I got some balloons really oh yes
because I did the same this is my 30th
and I was going to post the same picture
well I got one and an m and my sister
bought them and my housemate came down
and because they'd like floated that way
around he thought it said M1 am I
celebrating the M1
because it was a long journey Jack you
know it's a metaphor
no one really did anything special for
mine I'm still not waiting for that to
be I went to one to 1.4 like within a
day there's no point in hitting a
milestone if you don't take the lips off
the way you hit it if you're not hitting
it by like [__] smashing it well I I
my 900k podcast ready a release
and and I hit the million before I could
get the podcast out so it was like
really uh I was in thanks Logan by the
way for that um but then again he's
ripped my podcast off now it's a fair
play to him you know I mean give and
take I've done it better yeah it must be
nice to have a a guest book on all these
nice things and he got deji on yeah yeah
and sort of a pull of having that kind
of you know I'm Logan Paul come talk to
me whereas we're just basically sorry
can we have a chat yeah it's annoying
you know you're struggling when you've
got me for a fourth time yeah
think there's a few people here I think
Will's got the record right now well I
mean Lawrence technically yeah I'm just
a lucky hanger on
cheers
thanks for joining us today that was the
Christmas podcast
soon let's promote that promote that get
it well um all right Stephen's funny so
I brought Mommy to her thank you very
much you're banging on the table a lot
uh this week after one of the best
series that I've done and people can't
wait to see it this week on the Internet
it's not gonna be about the week
the show yet to be honest you can
actually know what it's about yeah we'll
see honestly we don't even know so it's
going to be and yet people have bought
tickets Alexa suck on that that's right
you're not wrong what have you ghost
writers come up with uh I don't know
Alex what sort of things have you got
down all right so I obviously I'll just
end up writing it foil in the end anyway
that's what that's what I've got not
genuinely one of my mates from school
like taxes are the only girls or me uh
me nieces wanting to kind of this
YouTuber have you have you ever heard of
these two Lads and I was like 30 good
for VIP yeah
by the way Chuck sorry
it does yeah did you get a Yankee Candle
with it as well no so they're going to
meet you afterwards you get a wanky
handle all right I think it's before I
think it's before what um have you ever
had any weird meeting we've had people
tweeting and saying what we should talk
about weird fine interactions myself but
we were out on a Christmas party last
night oh no like last week
right [__] out and there's one [__]
drunk book literally hanging onto his
shoulder gun you've got to beat that
Logan Paul it's literally [__] in one
hand and like on his shoulder that's how
my meeting yeah I will yeah
be fair calyx is a real mess
so that was that was a recent experience
my worst one was because of you that's
my worst one and we were both insomnia
and you tweeted everybody who goes to
make time Alex today punch him and the
thing is this world said it to do it
people actually went and did it I have
one guy come up to me and just start
boxing me well not quite uh I put up a
fight I always punch my fans that's what
I did I will clip that out but oh I had
someone turn up at my house and she was
from Cambridge and I'm from Norwich and
you've got a lot of women fans by the
way
a lot of women have like said on my
comments like um I I phoned you through
Chuck Smith I was like maybe there is a
benefit maybe there's finally an upside
of having this conference it's just
[__] hell I think my emotions she
like knocked on the door and was like um
oh yeah I can have a photo because this
was way back when and I used to put my
actual address in my banner you [__]
no no
teacher so people would send me like
Christmas presents I could open and she
just rocked up and she was like can I
come into your house such a different
time in it yeah I know and she came in I
was like I'm not too sure and then I was
like yeah can do and she came in because
apparently the light was better I was
like how did you get here she was like
my parents dropped me off America how
old was she
was [__] young she was about 11 12.
I was like I don't know what to do but
the lighting was better inside
my Chad's still there now you're my
million friends
I've watched a documentary about [__]
like that last night where this uh this
last got kidnap and uh like she was 14
and then 18 years later she turned up
she'd had a couple of kids with a
[__] kidnap her and uh the mortgage
for the Steve he got arrested he got
arrested but the kids were so attached
to him they thought like dad's going to
prison and like the kids didn't want to
go to prison they were like ask me dad
well it was it was
Sweden Sweden
um we're sending me videos of him um
he's petting something else in the video
uh it was it was basically it was a dog
sled so you get like four really eager
dogs and then the dogs just pull you
around the Arctic Circle for example
how'd they make Amiga what if one of
them don't want it I want to be fair
some of them didn't want it and they
they were talking candles
one in the head
to be fair while I was out there I
thought this would be a really good XO
video this would be a great trip
anything with dogs
I just said I'd [__] anything with dogs
the dogs are so sweet
dogs am I right just a sec we had Segway
is your biggest video the one with the
girl with the dogs
imagine your biggest video ever being
the last shot [__] dogs that is
honestly that's what I said in the video
somewhere in the city some girls dad
come up to me and went you're that guy
that does the videos about the women
[__] dogs oh that's my life
yeah that's good yeah but that's
everyone what's like the main main one
just name it Emma chamber yeah
yeah well she's like an American vlogger
who does like
I mean we've did uh we've got the
karaoke machine so I'll get out at the
end we'll all have a good singer we're
gonna go in Christmas carols yeah do
this you destruct run repeat Yeah well
yeah
we did EXO secret santa I got um Stephen
um remote control Audi R8 so oh no your
friends that your mate's got an Audi all
right and and also a Batman mask someone
got them a Batman mask as well
and it but it's a level up on mine yeah
I think uh was there anyone get a peep
from from Al jezza no no no no nothing
like that I get tagged in videos boxing
now
we've all been there for about three
weeks the dodgy shoulder I've got a
dodgy shoulder uh I'm not sure boxing's
for him he's still not over getting
dropped by Arsenal
have you seen that video where he says
he was the best footballer on the ball
yeah during the year that the inventor
yeah that guy buying that video
there's a there's an I think there's a
new culture on YouTube and really
everyone in in this room is typically up
for it where it's like if
if if we take on a big YouTuber and make
them look a complete [__] then you're
banging views and you're starting it's
like vultures yeah you're starting your
career
I was going to say role of a million but
sorry uh people got to come after us
next and that's not okay when do the
crowd turn when they go hold on a minute
you guys are guys you guys are the ones
we [__] don't like anymore yeah
that's when the next Generation come up
how do you avoid that then how do you
how do you I'm not saying the n-word's a
good show yeah yeah don't be shout
definitely shout that's right that's a
building block try not to be a sexist
[__] that's what I'd say yeah
sorry
I do get a lot of comments in me video
saying um are you still sexist yeah so
why are you I'm not it's a joke though
in 2018 you can't even joke about the
differences between men and women
anymore it's ridiculous like you can
talk about anything else other than that
pretty much pretty much apart from other
differences we'll find out what we can't
joke about in this podcast yeah you
can't say that at 2 43. uh Japanese war
slave not you sorry Brian sorry this is
good
and how much about you ABS I don't know
are you excited for the tour Lads yeah
we're a bit nervous not really
I feel like once once we've written it
and we've like got really good jokes
that we know will work it'll be exciting
we haven't got that yet so yeah nervous
when is it March or something uh yeah
end of March April uh yeah how many days
12 no 10 but 12 nights it's a lot of
money for that
10 days two shows in one they're really
working as hard the second chair is
going to really struggle let's be honest
good luck
yeah yeah we have a great live show
story don't we jack what's up
we're not supposed to mention this are
we not no because you're meant to make
out like it went really well it did go
well it says that now well it went
better than we expected the actual show
went well right
um I carried you uh but but the tickets
were free so obviously people just got
them and then just didn't Rock up so
we've had about a third of the capacity
and and I think we didn't put many on
anyway because we just wanted to be a
little show just to see how it was going
and what was that it was meant to be 100
yeah
now I think you'll find if you look
closer most of the tickets were bought
by one person yeah I bought the first
five rows just something thought okay
came down a peg or two all right there's
one podcast in Castle set up your own
podcast again about
um what 30 tops yeah it was like a mini
conference meeting but it was like it
was really awful it was really
yeah right and there was a bit where
like Alex was talking it was like one
bit where he was talking but I got um a
celebration and ate the chocolate and
was just like flicking it off not
thinking anyone was looking at me and
then everyone started laughing and I was
like that is the biggest laugh I [__]
got tonight that I can't flick a wrap
her off my finger that's not gonna
happen every [__] week yeah live
podcasts are awkward because they're not
scripted though so like it must be the
easiest hour and like hour and a half's
worth of money you've ever made the live
podcast
Stephen's the problem Steven's the real
problem
um
moving on
Stephen you've done a gig that uh field
once uh when you booked to do um you
were booked to do something after a
religious meeting once it wasn't I
wasn't told it was a religious meeting
it was a it was a you know Christmas
party I was told all right on a company
based in Saint Helens however the
headquarters was Saint Helens and there
was only six employees from there the
rest was from all over the world
and they were sort of like uh
they're like
pharmaceutical experts uh and just
before
you're all exactly and the guy goes uh
there's a large like it's largely Muslim
based right okay
I saw my tattoo
Merry Christmas it just said like they
won't be drinking so you know it might
be a bit of a weird gig and I was just
like okay anyway it might not be
drinking
I go on an hour late and uh well they
were late an hour so not you but
unfortunately just before I go up they'd
had a briefing on the year and they did
badly apparently so they got told off
then they had to read him from the Quran
and
that's talking about his non-sex life
did not go away Brian uh
I did a show for BBC three that was
about moving out oh yeah can you move
out with your mum and dad without your
mum and dad I remember no and then they
needed like a story arc no yeah so
halfway through they were like what do
you want to do what's your career I was
like be a stand-up I asked you halfway
through halfway through it was almost
like they hadn't planned it and then it
got to like the second to last day you
know what he does yeah
so they um they booked me a gig it's a
little Pub in Norwich I've never been to
and they told me the morning off so they
were like you got a gig tonight [__] it
now so I was like I don't know what to
do so I just I don't know if anyone
knows the Twitter account Uber Facts
yeah and they're clearly not yeah yeah
so I just got loads of that those and
was like I'll just rip these off yeah
and then I got to the pub and there was
a grown man on the floor in a suit
crying and I was just like first time
you met Ryan yeah
I was like what's this deal and then the
bar
his dad's died so I was like cool um
but my um there was like three people
stood there watching me and um I was in
the corner and my first joke which was
obviously [__] was if people don't laugh
at your jokes statistically they're more
likely to find you attractive brilliant
so I was like so so I was like so if
you're not laughing hello like that but
there was one guy and it's not a boner
in the corner there was actually a
Muslim guy in the front and I don't know
why
but I don't know why so I looked at him
as if to say like so if you don't laugh
you clearly fancy me and he went and
walked off and then there was two people
well I spoke to him after yeah yeah and
I went sorry about that joke and he was
like that's fine
in my face whatever no I did speak to
him your career is over yeah it's all
over I spoke to him after do you still
and he said he really liked my Facebook
video yeah yeah yeah yeah the call to
action do you
do you um do you still Harbor like hopes
of being a comedian in the long run he's
a comedian
1 million subscribers yeah in the long
run do you still want to be fine no like
do you still want to do like stand up
stand up or do you still want to go on
tour and do that there's a lot of money
on that by the way
the plan was to do stand up and then we
done this podcast and it was really
[__] easy and I thought I'd just do
that we haven't exactly the same yeah um
but seriously would you I would like to
do it yeah yeah and have you sort of got
things oh yeah yeah yeah Humanity I'm
going to call the first one yeah this is
Ricky gerace from 10 years ago yeah it's
like karaoke but the jokes that's
brilliant that's really good you just
mailed along to a Ricky Germaine's act
yeah doing that every two minutes
with a [__]
we've been asked to um talk about other
like awkward moments generally if you've
got any uh awkward moments Lads why are
you looking at me in Lawrence yeah I
feel like Lawrence would have a notebook
the other day where I was at um the
other day yeah where I was at a station
and the guy went uh
anyway can I have a selfie I went yeah
sure and my friend was with me I was
like what
and he and he was like oh man
and we both just stood there and he went
gone man
I was like well you went it's gonna have
to be on your phone because my phone's
died
and so I had to take the picture and
then send it to him that's a pistol
don't even post it I've got too much
I was actually on the [__] train the
[__] train not the Virgin train
train banter that's good
I'm glad he didn't say nothing I was on
a train I was on a train you guys
already watched my words with Stephen
and Lawrence around just scare me
they'll attack anything I say don't make
a cup of tea I want to try Lawrence
McKenna must be some some kid just
walked past and like screams at me look
at him like well I'd just sat on the
train George [__] off Josh please leave
me alone and then it was an empty
Carriage I heard a pitbull with nobody
on it on purpose I don't talk to anyone
uh I don't know
Brian calls it oh yeah now I've got a
million better than everybody I know uh
so I was just sat there and he screamed
and before he said anything to me I'd
already pulled his phone out to take a
picture and I'm looking at him and I
don't even know what's going on I was
confused like what I'd even done at that
point
um and then he just took a picture of
him he walked off didn't say it didn't
say a word oh I heard that but I had a
boots meal deal in my mouth as I was
doing it so he went oh and he had his
iPad and he went over and took a pic
you have the whole meal deal in your
mouth
I actually had someone do this similar
thing come up to me I was walking along
the Victoria Station and he goes
you're that YouTuber I'm like no I mean
because I'm thinking if you don't know
who the [__] I am you don't watch it
that much [__] you [__] so I'm keep
walking and he goes I was like what's my
name then he's like
no I'll see you later so ironically that
man was Adam
was with me Paul was just cringing but
actually it's it's funny we should bring
this up because when I tweeted this out
used two both noticed this there was a
guy on saying yeah
what should we talk about my favorite
thing was in that in that in that tweet
you guys I go by the name of it yeah
yeah by the name anyway Lawrence uh
because uh talk about people coming from
nothing that have now earned what they
have and ignoring people that are coming
from nothing check your Facebook I go by
Jonathan Hubbard
I did check your face because I thought
what's your biggest what's your problem
hello TJ I have a proposition for you
I'm a 19 year old actor and I have I've
been acting for five years and every day
in some way another I knock on the
industry's door I have a concrete
mindset and I sharpen my craft to an
obsessive degree to be honest with you I
haven't got many rules recently shock
but um however I have been creating I
have been creating work that I post
online those videos consist of different
characters and scenes that I created on
myself I will send you the links if
you're interested I am determined and I
like this one I am determined as an ox
is that really I mean literally
every character I do in a film is a part
of my legacy
so I ask you true Geordie will you have
me on the true Geordie podcast
[Music]
advice 11 year olds into his house so I
wouldn't think anything else
you said it just skip this podcast
I love I'm gonna release this as a clip
with no reference to that at all
um
[Music]
I imagine this is what Wills like when
he goes back to Newcastle aren't you
what yeah is there a YouTuber in the
house yes
yeah apparently I'm a model these days
whilst we're bragging Toby carvery DM me
on Twitter offering me a free jumper
thank you I'll take it you can come in
the post oh well next year
I know but they can see they're watching
behind the cameras
I got a VK Christmas jumper sensor
really yeah PlayStation really love you
as well yeah I know yeah you sucking
them up VK VK is in
not even wkd
VK gives me horrendous flashbacks from
uni I [__] yeah hey I've just got to
play my PlayStation classic by the way
shout out to them um everyone got one
apart metal gear solid playthrough just
started it coming out on the second
Channel soon just promote it's not on
the little one yeah yeah it's tiny I was
a bit disappointed by that I mean it's
gonna be an actual replica
it isn't the grid system
what's the point tiny controllers as
well
I've received nothing from any brand the
controllers are the same size aren't
they I think they're the same as the old
PlayStation they're not the jaw shot
ones the jaw shot ones felt bigger
because they don't have the oh
situations uh by the way a confession I
once uh met a girl's parents for the
first time uh actually it was a
Christmas time they all sat around
having their like a dinner on Christmas
Eve or whatever and I'm just stood up
like yep I don't know like I was here 18
19 quite awkward you know what I mean
you're meeting them for the first time
I had a bit of a beard but it wasn't she
was a beard
she was hot actually
um credit to us she had uh anyway
I'm about to say I um I talked to them
for about half an hour stood up in that
and uh just before I'm about to go her
brother pops up and goes just so you
know mate you've had your fly down the
entire time you've been talking to her
and I was like and you've been wanking
why did you get what was happening
um
she's with you bro it didn't go very
well do you consider yourself to be a
bit of a smooth talker I mean I could
talk to women so back in the day when
you were going out were you like
chirpsing isn't it yeah were you a big
trip
I never thought I'd let you say that
yeah were you a big church
up until about 17 it you know I was
nervous as any guy would be but I don't
know if something just clicked and we
had where I stopped caring
for sure
Alexis
no I was um I was having believe it or
not sex with a woman once and um you
know like sometimes when like for a
change
I just want to see what all the fuss is
about and I'm very awkward at the best
of times but like
um people think I'm making this up I've
told it in so many videos I wouldn't
keep on with it that's why this happened
it's a good bit though and
um she her mum came was like shouting at
her through the dog she had a bald socks
correctly have you come yet she was like
you keep throwing the socks the wrong
way she came in the room there was no
duvets this was in the summer and
and I've just gone because the door was
there I've just gone and looked at the
wall because I can't bear to look and
she stood there I reckon it must have
been 30 seconds which is a long amount
no I'm just saying instantly I'm barely
up anyway
and then she's going are you the way you
bought a socks like the orange don't go
with the black and I'm like what the
[__] is going on and that man's wearing
no clothes he's got Odd Socks
and then uh yeah and then she left after
30 seconds she knew you were there oh
she knew I was there yeah
that's good that's good that's good yeah
that's weird though isn't it I've been
caught but not that bad uh there was a
girl I used to see um me and her dad got
on really I obviously I grew up without
a dad relationship and her dad didn't
have a son he had three daughters or
whatever so like me and him were bonding
all that and uh we used to go like
fishing and stuff like that so I was
getting on well to sleep with him no no
I was getting on sucking him off I have
the three daughters walking I was
absolutely
stop and leave it in his mouth just wait
until they're done just you just gotta
let it go so
genuinely that I I had a real thing for
this girl all right this was one of the
fittest girls I've ever [__] in me
life right and her dad was sewn and I
was like you know what it is this is
going really well I'm really happy with
this but anyway she had um she had a
bedroom that was upstairs and her window
faced out onto the Main Street and uh
one day one day we're uh we're getting
down to it and the blinds are sort of
tilted and upward angle and apparently
and I didn't realize this but whenever I
died used to drive past the house and
turn around and park up he'd always look
through the blinds and they were angled
in such a way that um on one lucky day
or in luckiest for his maybe
um I was eating our ass out
and I'm talking into her ass like I've
got a serious illness and the Cure is in
her butthole do you know what I'm saying
so
um so anyway uh we're here sort of the
dog or and then that's when we realize
like oh [__] he must have seen But then
I'm like probably not you know you can't
look at the window every [__] time
you talk it's in great form fellow yeah
no I mean this the smell would have
still been on my face as I'm coming
downstairs anyway so anyway
she he comes through the door and I'm
just thinking just act like nothing's
happening just Breeze this
he never made eye contact me with ever
again
I thought we had something special
I I think but the enemy had I thought
afterwards would it have been better if
I was just [__] uh what is it is it
the fact that I was a rim job's weird do
you know what I mean
neither way okay
situation no but like
if you're looking at your daughter in a
certain way is it better because then
you know she's a bit of a freak then do
you know what I mean is that not the
kind of child you want to read at least
you know she's clean though
I'll tell you
you bought her up properly
household you could have eaten your
dinner off of that thing you did
oh damn
I forget this is a Christmas party if
people are watching this on Christmas
Day if you're doing a rim job
the stuffing was
[Music]
I'm gonna eat my Christmas dinner and
put this on for the family especially
now I know this is gonna happen
oh it was good times how do you have um
because you did something
um we'll record it after and then drop
it in cheers so do you have any
Christmas traditions that you go through
that is one of them yeah he goes around
to a house every year and he goes I'm
back
uh I'm I'm PR I like to watch The
Godfather after I've had me dinner and I
have it with them a bug of a bag of
toffees and I just sit
here
like do you know I've never had though
when we're talking about women in that
Christmas do you know obviously girls
dress up like Santa Claus like uh
never had that can we talk about what
you just dressed up as just before we do
this
it's downstairs no I would have done but
I'll put it in the video they'll see it
they'll see you'll get
and many
he's lying
I never checked on a roundabout you can
relate to this
have I have you do you remember that do
you yeah do you remember that a little
bit tipsy bribe but we went for it
no is that you referring around about I
thought you were saying we shagged on
around here I need something to stop me
from getting [__] [__] stop it this
is Christmas sorry yeah
Alex has gone through two pint pops of
champagne I mean
I'm impressed to be fair Jack did say
that this was going to end up being um
five men on Alex by the end of it spit
roasting them
are you up for that one I'm gonna be
pouring more then I do not want to be
sober
[Laughter]
have you seen our picture of Stephen
tries dressed as you by the way I wasn't
dressed as you this isn't an attack yeah
I'm going to show Chad the picture of
Stephen just as Alex uncanny yeah
I see your complexion and we've got
Vodka in there where is it all right
is it in the it's in the fridge isn't it
go and check the fridge
so we haven't really made any topics for
this one we've got um people have asked
us to review the yeah we've kind of done
a lot of this before do we do we do this
I had a good question YouTube Rewind
or somebody somebody said what you
reckon the worst thing a YouTuber's
gonna do next year is that's a good one
I was thinking about this because I was
asking about my repair in a script where
I could like be fill in the blanks so
that I could have like 10 videos
prepared for what day to me I was in
2018 is it's kind of like one of those
years that will stand out I think I'll
be surprised if in I think I think this
is going to be one that people look back
at because so much Monumental good and
bad things happen we will never top this
summer the [__] Heat Wave pints and
Kieran trippy has right foot yeah it
doesn't I was texting me like where do
we go from there yeah
she was like that's a [__] I'm being
[__] serious I can't actually watch
the recap of it on either like the
summer of love thing I can't watch it
because it'll bring back so many
memories
prove your heart is that the fact that
times were so good yeah it was sunny and
[__] pints just YouTube for that
summer didn't you I just
remember Jack hasn't made it made a
video in ages I checked Instagram and
it's just him in the bar everything
just an absolute State an absolutely
do you love your country do you love you
all right
you've seen his Facebook videos
yeah yeah I've got a funny
joke that's causing a bit of trouble
I've got a funny Tommy Robinson Story
actually go on to do with um weirdly the
Logan fight um I'm at the weigh-in
um and uh weirdly we're all like sort of
you know doing my thing oh everyone come
on stage waiting but uh and you just see
Tommy Robinson in the audience
before it was one of the weirdest like
random moments in my life and um we're
Furious if we'd normally was coming we
would have like not allowed him in who
this is Tommy which stuff uh you know
to be fair that would do views
um so uh the the studio Stuart stuff who
runs beside myself
they're like we wish we'd known he was
crumbly used a fake name or whatever
anyway thank you very much
as you remember
uh the former heavyweight champion of
the world was knocking around
um let's go champ I thought you're
talking about Tommy Robinson
Shannon brexit bearing in mind like
Shannon Briggs is one of the few human
beings that I've looked at and thought
[__] hell you are big like he just
he's a huge man he's like he's just
massive right
after after we finish the day I go to
the bar naturally I grab a drink and I'm
like [__] me thing [__] that's all there
Tommy runs
[Laughter]
I was like yeah fair enough um no
worries uh Shannon comes over he spots
Tommy Robinson and he goes
and I'm like what am I about to win like
in my head I'm thinking the heavyweight
champion like this
yeah and Tommy Robinson looks tiny next
to him yeah racist to black man an
Irishman walking and he goes uh
Shannon goes to Tommy you that guy that
hates Muslims and I'm just like [__]
they I I didn't get my camera or
something this is yes that's me
Tommy looks at his eyes like like the
look The Only Could Be fear that is all
I can say I didn't say no what the hell
is about to happen and he just nervously
giggled and and as Shannon's going
towards him in almost slow motion
Tommy just sits there and just I think
he just prays at that moment he's just
thinking what the [__] is wrong he
converted to Islam and Shannon just
grabs him and hugs him and puts this
tiny little head into his [__] huge
Chestnut it's all right man I don't mind
I think you funny and I'm just saying
that's exactly what time he was going
for yeah
and Tommy's just like his little peanut
head's getting squished between this
[__] boyfriend and all this oh I
don't know someone else had him or
something it was just it it was mental I
was like that could have gone so many
different ways that is amazing imagine
saying to somebody you're the guy who
hates Muslims and then your next action
is to embrace them in a hug
uh that was surprised at that I was like
you know I don't know what faith Shannon
Briggs is but I thought it could have
gone [__] I mean let's be honest a
fight would have been over very quickly
between those two yeah Tommy would have
won yeah but but Shannon I don't know he
just didn't seem to give up video of uh
Tommy like beating up them three gazers
to come up to him in the street though I
have never seen anything like it there's
like three guys obviously come up to him
like call him a racist whatever you win
he just takes his jack off and starts
fighting him and he's he's handled
himself well I thought I'm not gonna sit
here and go fair play but fair play
no I was watching I was like do not I
don't like the Muslims
the only one I've seen is where this is
a guy gets out like a guy walks towards
him yeah
I think the thing is to be Tommy
Robinson you have to be game at the very
least because you are going to be
attacked Tommy Robinson
because you two are sort of first time
we met he told me he played for
Bournemouth no I didn't I didn't yeah
I said I played in Bournemouth as in the
area
that works in gay but it isn't these two
have a lot of fun all right are you can
you actually play football though yeah
it's got a lot of football boots no the
first time we met you and oh yeah I was
playing Sunday League it was 1-1 no I'll
stop myself back on 90th minute scored a
goal yeah
that was my second goal of the entire
season
if we were doing a Fireside team I could
pick the first player I'd go Brian in
five aside really good you played yeah
I'm weird and weirdly good it could be
something to do the fact that you'd have
to run much in five years that's it
though no because actually you you do
move a lot inside the side so there's
not much room and he takes up halfway
this is where the Bournemouth story
comes in because the reason why I don't
have to run so much in Fireside because
two of my mates used to play for the
Bournemouth Academy so I let them do all
the work and I would just I would start
and you know in five or so it's fine
you're getting off sides in five or size
so I just stand by the goal they cheat
it hit a goalkeeper to come back I put
it in it's a surprise Jack makes happy
hours as good as it isn't it because
[__] me do you know what like foreign
did you leave them Alex and move on to
proper place
he was the best on the ball player at
the club at the club yeah yeah
oh good times good times I don't care
about you
I've got alcohol left I was gonna drink
my sorrow away
there's milk and gin there yeah
a beautiful place
um I sort of seeing her a few times
because he used to go like every week
desperate for [__] bushes
yeah I was in this club and uh
there's like the there's a proper Ketty
place it's St Helens we've all been
there yeah and and I went to I went oh
could I buy your drink she's like yeah
uh so I went to buy it and they just go
uh yeah we don't take card so I just
turned to her and go oh at least
yeah yeah I thought you didn't have
enough money no that's a Sprint of the
street came back and uh that was
tragically
[Music]
I can't believe that when Stephen said a
Ketty place you went yeah we've all been
there yeah
see if I joke about everything nobody
will know what I actually do and don't
do oh right okay
that's like me yeah
we've all been there mate
didn't mention Ollie White's merch in
your million subscriber video I was just
I was just wearing it you know it's
[__] depressing Hollywood white owns
a percentage of the company that do my
merch Ollie white is creaming off of
willingly invest purely because body
weight is the Suge Knight of YouTube
merch he's sitting there like a Don just
watching all these minions make his
money yeah you [__] person he's
sitting there in a bath of beans
I am the [__] [__] that's in there I
am the table you know what I mean it's
just brother Paul said another team
speaking of that group there's some beef
that we have to talk about now have you
seen Casper versus Josh Peters I thought
you were getting in the boxing thing
with Josh Petersburg Josh came on our
podcast
um last week
did you chilling no it's not out no I
would have known yeah yeah no you're a
big fan I am actually I do watch you
again what's happening I don't know
what's happening are you gonna box him
well I've done [__] all for the last
three weeks
since October why why is Casper are they
just trying to make something happen for
the sake of some views or something I
Dimensions
[Music]
going out Christmas Day oh yeah
it's real now no it always it's real now
but when it's not real anymore
it's not real no genuinely I think um it
just looks like a really fake I saw a
tweet the other day I thought that hit
it on the nail on the head and it was
KSI versus Harry was you like cocaine
and ketamine KSI versus deji was [__]
brother beef or whatever and then KSI
versus Randolph was like literally dead
she's a pedophile these lot have set it
up as oh you didn't flush the toilet
yeah like come on I didn't really write
that though yeah super cyber and beef is
fake they faked the cutic daddy of being
a pedophile and that's the new level
you've never done that would you no I
don't Fake It generally the amount of
people or YouTubers Alex is out there
does Peter foils are you really like
he's
yeah
so I have a really terrible track record
at befriending Peter Park don't say that
everyone always asks me what does he
look like
pedophiles how is your roommate
uh no George is what do you like to live
with it doesn't really leave his room
does he yeah I say well more than I say
George oh really see when I met him when
he came on the Pod last week whatever I
felt like because he's got a very
distinctive voice because you can't see
him yeah
you all know him I'd never seen what he
actually looked like so when I met him I
thought I was trying to think the voice
don't match the person but it doesn't
the [__] handshake does the do you
shake his hand I think so this time over
shook his hand he now he took me hand
off really
it's quite a serious slug when you talk
to him so when when I met you and him in
the pub and he was quite like serious
and straight like you were I was an
idiot I was losing my mind he was off
his tits when I first met him no I've
had we've all been there you told will
that you thought I was on drugs I wasn't
obviously
I didn't say is he on drugs William or
is that the after
party's name
it was your it was Stephen's fault so
when I first met you I was losing my
mind because Max turned up yeah he's
your friends
what happened he encouraged me to do two
shots of I don't know what it was two
shots of Cattleman to be honest
for the entire party I just felt like I
woke up the next day uh after meeting
you and I woke up outside my apartment
either
I didn't wake up outside my out like in
the in in the apartment building I woke
up I looked up and I went that's the top
of my apartment building that's concrete
yeah I was I was very confused at where
I was and it was like nine o'clock in
the morning I had no idea what was going
on you're not normally up there
one of the questions we've had about you
specifically is um
the other YouTuber who is called Charles
um people are asking has he [__] you
what James Charles yeah
that was one of the questions I mean
Eric
I uploaded uh well I'm saying you
thought it was very funny didn't you
well because you were the only first
pointed out do you think do you think
men with men is funny do you will
wow what happened I uploaded a video on
a YouTuber called James Charles I was
doing a response to something he'd done
that was controversial
um and I decided I guess I decided to
wear I mean I wasn't even tight trousers
uh you kind of see where this is going
I just I am a huge [__] basically now I
was wearing uh jeans but I didn't
realize I recorded the first minute for
the first time ever with my lower half
of my body in shock that was a mistake
yeah did you have um what was it it all
right I wasn't like yes I get to [__]
ruin another YouTuber it's obvious you
see the outline of his pain right okay
okay yeah he's the one with a big penis
it's quite obviously an LGBT YouTuber
James Charles he does makeup videos I've
seen him before is he the one with the
shaved sides of the head yeah
I think I did um I did a reaction to one
of his videos once where he goes um
these are all knockoff products yes and
he's like really happy with himself yeah
that would be James I remember just
being like how the hell did I get here I
just remember I woke up the next I
checked I checked the real time our
video's doing really well I didn't read
the comments all the girls watch it
Joe Charles followed you back and I was
like oh cool well at least you didn't
take the video badly and the first DMV
sent me was oh you got a huge [__] wow
it was like I couldn't watch the video I
was too distracted by them just
distracted by the Bulge basically was
what he said and I I read that and I was
no [__] weird that must have been the
most mental do you know how much money
that guy makes though [__] just get I
read my wife yeah
and a half a month so I I read that I
read I read the yeah
he's telling us about a YouTuber trying
to shut them up I read the DM and I was
like oh well oh hopefully it's not that
obvious I mean he's a gay man maybe he
was looking for it well I read the
comments and it had like all of them had
like 10 000 likes do you have a big dick
then
I
has anyone else been chatted up by a
YouTuber and asked about their dick
because I I'm a bit annoyed now
I feel like you're the only one here
who's being asked about their dick off
another YouTube Vic star is a lovely guy
and I'll never top him in come on
you'll take that to your grave Stephen
[Applause]
you've been you're being offered some
good dick there in terms of money good
day good CPM if keemstar is right then I
will be making those movies well
literally you could literally suck a
dick in the story about the Nick
Crompton gay prank yeah
no Nick yeah Nick message Jack and
Steven
's like oh Alex's face
oh yeah yeah he texted me and was like
uh like the new pod can you it is Alex
Kane I was like he's bi so he might be
well I mean
I haven't made it up no I mean are you
Keen I know you buy yeah
why do you think George gets all those
hickeys
when he wakes up and he goes you [__]
doing it again if anyone likes um if
anyone likes Alex's [__] just leave a
like on the videos
this is
Merry Christmas everyone this is awesome
I was the first person that Nick
Crompton came out to really yeah yeah
yeah really yeah and a funny story
you're not the most understanding person
normally though well no it's not about
that I just mean we're in a collab
channel oh really at the time yeah we
had a collab Channel called project six
Joe Weller was in it for the first week
and then he got the World Cup songs he
[__] up
never saw him again
Crawford you don't you know he's one of
those people who will you'll not hear
from him for a while that's just yeah
yeah
since that week
it's a joke about it let's not do it now
all right so you you and Nick Crompton
are good well we used to be uh good pals
yeah yeah so what was that like well so
I have this weird story
I'll be intrigued to see what you guys
think of this yeah but in a roundabout
kind of way I think would you be okay
with you sharing this with us though oh
yeah definitely yeah I think I am kind
of at fault for Jake Paul bringing Jake
Paul to the world right wow so I'll give
you a little bit alone Nick Nick hated
you so much if he moved to Los Angeles
very much yeah yeah so Norwich of
America so I I told this in a podcast
but it never went out so exclusive for
you my friend but um I started a collab
Channel called project six and there was
five of us and we needed someone for the
sixth day and Nick Crompton was a fanboy
of Jack mate way back in the day so
pathetic and
um
I watched a couple of his videos and I
thought he was quite funny like a little
Peter K he used to do comedy like
Northern what makes you think is open
okay like he was just chubby and
Northern
I knew that I just wanted to hear and
see it yeah after Christmas
so bread he is actually funny
it's quite funny loud I like that when
he did the response video the Bazinga
calling him out and he turned around in
his um his uh chair I think he might
have been struck in a cat or some [__]
it was funny
oh yeah but these two absolutely to be
fair this is going to end up in one of
those Instagram videos where it does all
the weird transitions
next podcast don't put those two
together yeah we never do we always we
always shoot EXO separately with those
two apart yeah so your Nick's your fan
boy so I had to convince the other guys
on the podcast who was well uh a guy
called um chip daddy Adam waif was in it
yeah yeah this is going back a few years
now I fell off but he never got up I
don't know who these are but I that's
the one that JJ said at the um
Elliot Crawford he's like you'll be uh
what do you say YouTubers
Channel yeah it was funny it was quite a
nice restaurant but so yeah so I
convinced those guys to get Nick on the
channel and he he went to 10K Subs
banged it and then um yeah so he then he
then tried to get a job at social change
so obviously you've had Steve Bartlett
on the podcast the guy that runs that
we've all tried it big duffed up we got
I've been there for Nick's um what's it
called um when you try and get a job you
need to prove yourself something like
that he basically
well here I just say this is the most
YouTuber
he had to prove that he could get x
amount of traffic to a certain video so
he asked me and Joe and we pushed some
views to this video so we got the job at
Social chain long story short he landed
this great job and then he called me up
and I was in my dad's flat and he was
like I'm gonna move to America I was
like why are you doing that you've just
got a great job he was like oh there's a
Vine star that I'm gonna start managing
I was like who's this he gave the name
Jake Paul's I've never heard of this guy
so he went over managed him made him a
big thing so I think in a weird kind of
way you're full in it it's I'm at fault
for Jake Paul
I made Nick Crompton right and he
matched it yeah and he made Jake Paul
and Jake Paul
wouldn't mind me saying that but you
made Jake Paul exactly exactly and
that's where Brian's friend's room now
so technically you're right you made you
made Brian friends with Jake Paul
you're welcome I know yeah yeah but when
we I was in a hotel room with um Nick
Crompton once and Stevie who's the other
guy on our podcast and the other one
this is the Forgotten man
he hasn't got enough [__] subscribers
this is before Nick came out so he's in
the opposite room and then I said to
Steve
shut up you two
[__] hell I was like when Nick comes
through let's leave the jaw the door
slightly ajar and we'll be in bed and
we'll take our clothes off and pretend
that we're up for something right so
Nick jumped right in as YouTube is right
it's all fake so we let Nick know what
we were gonna do yeah
nothing we do is yeah it was from a
second Channel years ago it's silly and
then Nick comes in and then he goes
we're in bed and he goes guys you're
ready he goes what the [__] you doing
what the [__] you and he acted really
offended at the fact that two boys were
in bed and then all the comments turned
against him and were like you're a
homophobic bastard and then a month
later he come out as gay so I say he's
not actually gay but you should come out
as gay he's actually homophobic he's
just kept that going all this time well
I've got him he's having sex I hate this
it's a my man going why are you balling
socks like that it's horrible yeah that
sounds amazing
Nick can manage me if he wants and I
mean that
New Year's
carry on
I'll go back also if you're it's like
Efron game
just for the record it requires the
other person also
is he gay no but no but he's the fittest
man I've ever seen why do you keep
drinking that yeah there's a mixer for
the Vodka do not need
oh where are you going where are you
going
that's like the Rolf Harris set I feel
sorry
it's nice watching this from the outside
this podcast oh yeah yeah I've never
touched a kid apart from my uh nephew
that's my kids respond he cries when I
touch him it's gonna be a lot of editing
on this one everyone knows just like I
said to my girlfriend keep it in
is there anybody else I'd really like
else to drink something
um I think I'd have one of my songs I
think we've got gin uh vodka with mixers
we've got beers
we've got whiskey we've got cider
Stephen bring the whiskey out and I need
a little bring out the whiskey I'll have
a beer please if you bring out a beer
for me does anyone else want food
chicken yes
yeah when Jack drinks it perfectly
normal when I drink it oh look at that
[__] [__] I always drink this
yeah I know
help me highlights of the Year Lads what
are the highlights of the Year people
are asking
Croatia yeah
um
they're saying on YouTube
well everything he did KSI versus Joe
KSI versus Logan rise of ninja uh that
YouTuber who did that thing with us
sake little tear uh that kid who did
that thing with this 13 year old sister
where he pretend like he's there
because he's he's videos are [__] but
[__] his thumbnails are so obscene
the thing is if I wasn't tuned in so you
could be talking about 90 years
possibility the stone cold yeah I think
with him though I think he is the single
worst YouTuber on the platform like I
would say that above anyone else because
all right okay there's like yeah well I
walked past him and then he made a video
going oh he didn't say nothing to my
face that's what neither did you do we
literally walk past each other in a
corridor but I think he is the single
worst person on the platform I didn't
like I'd get my dad to stand next to him
and intimidate
can we understand why you think he's the
worst YouTuber that there is
I've not seen this kid so is this is
this Colony yeah I get that he's bad but
it's just so bad that it's almost like
he kind of accepted it again you would
my other do you like the ship houses
it's because he's so like Unapologetic
so he'll like just do it and go yeah I
know
at the same time it's like it's bad in
the terms of like it's misleading your
stuff but I mean I do think that there's
obviously no form of I I don't
understand I don't know this video
should be like I'm really happy that
this did well but um oh there are
definitely there are worse people
that was that was Tommy that was Tommy
because that was when I met his friends
at uh one of the I think it was actually
the sidemen All-Stars game I met his
friends and he wasn't there really well
commentated event yeah and it was good
and Millie uh no it was uh Elmo films
tonight he's a lovely blind so who's the
one who is um
like the single worst YouTubers
that they've done just who would you say
is the worst YouTube I'm not up Stephen
I'm trying to think I think the worst
thing that happened last year because
you know we did the the podcast on it
yeah it's a slightly Friday uh but we
did the podcast on it and we said that
it was either uh daddy 05 yeah
um or it was the person who believed
that if they put a book in front of
their head and if I had a handgun for it
what he does not know that what a
girlfriend or boyfriend so they were
trying to go viral so a girl
obviously he puts two books in front of
his chest and he goes to his girlfriend
fire the [__] Desert Eagle
if they upload that that's a buyer yeah
well literally
died it went through the books and then
it was just killed him she's [__] in
[__] jail or whatever yeah what
coming soon to the chat meeting when did
this happen yeah my girlfriend kills
boyfriend
I think that was this year actually
weirdly um an Indian YouTuber just died
and I checked his uh yeah and it was
weird because the traffic's terrible
um
shout out to the Fred batch Instagram
page because they they cover a lot um
why is that so funny he just [__]
killed it doesn't he oh don't say it
what's your words yeah you'll never get
on Good Morning Britain with that if
Tyson Fury can do it I think I've got a
chance
who's your person of
2018. interesting one good question not
for that one
Maguire
like from from YouTube specific no no in
general General in the publication not
your neighbor Doris
um
I don't know
we'll come back to you can I ask you can
I ask you a question because you guys
are also well he's already asked one so
shall we answer that one
so Florence
that's all you guys ever end up feeling
sorry for the person that you've taken
the piss out yeah
occasionally
I think because sometimes I do videos
where I'll kind of go half and half I'll
be like well you're a bit of a prick but
also I don't think you're that much of a
prick uh and sometimes you know if
you're pregnant
what is the problem between you and
keemstar because uh I I personally my
experience with Kim has been fine like I
think he's been fine with me whatever
but you've had a dislike for ages it
seems like this is very weird because
it's one of those things where I like it
came and I'm like I still don't know if
it's real does that make sense I I look
at Kim I'm like I'll do it does he
actually hate me or is it like he's
playing with you that's always what he's
done so I always took it it's that to be
fair I always took it it's like pixel I
was like 50 he does it because maybe he
doesn't like what I've said 50 he does
it because the fact that he knows it
people will enjoy it because they do
enjoy it
um it's funny you only talk [__] about
people yeah it is funny because I I
watched him I've watched him before so I
can understand it's one of those things
where I remember it all started because
of the fact that at the beginning when I
had like 4 000 subscribers
um he did a video he did a debated
podcast which I don't know if that's
around anymore and he he called why not
friends with him anymore right yeah
we're not friends uh he caught one of my
one of one of my friends at the time he
said that he was untalented at the time
I thought he was actually the most
likely out of all of us
he wasn't afraid of fall I will say that
but I basically did a video saying that
I didn't literally it was a very simple
video he just went I don't agree with
you here's why and that was it it wasn't
I don't think it was necessarily mean or
anything and he did an entire two-hour
live stream on me and from that point
he's just kind of got out of hand you've
just like that's how you've got a
million tubs yeah
uh no it's one of those things where I
disagree with him once he didn't I agree
with me and from that point onwards I
did find a bit weird because that was
that was the first thing I said about
him on the Pod I just said he doesn't
research his his news and then he came
he done a whole [__] Twitter video
about me and said that I had frosted
tips
yeah
it's [__] terrible what's the first
thing I can see it's hair brilliant
[Applause]
Fiona comes in come on
I was in the car with Fiona yesterday
and I read an article and it said uh
bleached hair coming in for men next
year and Fiona straight away went will
tell him
he never goes against what you've said
he goes for a personal jab so why might
James replied to his child no I might
change he suck your dick out of his
mouth I'm gonna sort him out yeah the
thing is
I would say I'd like to disagree but Jay
I make James Murray did a video where he
replied to Keem and Kim replied saying
that's funny it obviously couldn't be
you who wrote it the funny thing is it
was me who actually told him to do the
joke so then James does a video where he
goes oh it was all Alex so you've just
complimented the guy who you apparently
hate so King so King Kingdom replies
again can't remember what we said
um so we we do it and it's about the
whole sucking up oh it was about a whole
I suck people off of views so we did a
video where James goes I got my
subscribers than Alex and and he and you
know why does he talk to me and halfway
through the video I appear from his
cross
because I love men
and I go and I just go am I doing a good
job and then James
push the spirit back down again he goes
carry on and the video ends and King
went that's funny you can look like that
yourself
um I mean it goes I mean he made some
comment about the fact that I was I was
like and obviously you got by 80 the
fact that he's bisexual and I was like
it's not a bad thing Daniel don't don't
go home a favor
I like when you call him Daniel that is
fine the only reason why I do that is
his fault uh he we spoke once in a
Discord call uh
yeah
and he said and I called him I called
him Daniel uh as to just just as a joke
I was like let's pretend that we're best
mates so I was like all right Daniel how
are you doing he went don't ever call me
Daniel again if you call me Daniel he's
like we're not friends we never be
friends and I went all right Daniel
anyway no don't do that I really don't
like it so from that point I've always
called him Daniel can you imagine a
grown man getting annoyed at someone
uses this is the best thing about the
whole team
every time every time King tweets me my
dad sends me a message and goes why is a
man my age talking to you on the
internet
yeah she's like Fair why is your dad
follow him does your dad call you on
Discord how does your dad contact
I mean I think what does your dad think
about you being friends with nonsense
uh I think at first
it was terrible and then yeah
[__] off he's gay but he plays football
so he's all right
but hold on
he wears those rainbow laces everywhere
I think the worst part is is when will
and George thought it was a very funny
idea to leak my earnings that's from my
dad's got something with respect for me
and George didn't lick it I said it
did the podcast how does everybody know
that you earned 50 Grands more than that
now
all right
I did a joke tweak as well was banned
off Twitter the other day and I joke I
did a tweet about will uh in all all his
his earnings to YouTube
from YouTube are about like uh
people like oh enjoy that three dollars
or that three quid I think [__] off
time's up by a thousand and then you're
close yeah that's not even before the
merch sales yeah
Stephen tries isn't his [__] elements
no I was trying to play You're welcome I
was trying to play well at a game of
FIFA the other day and every and I was
trying to play well at a game of FIFA
and every five minutes he gets this
uh-ching sound effects come from his
phone for every time
oh really yeah
absolutely
four dollars
[Music]
come on
keep that going baby all of a sudden
Ollie White's promoting one of these
merch on Instagram look if you like will
I need so much just keep buying this
[__] shovel it oh that's good that's
good that's good because it's ironic
that's the trailer yeah that's cracking
that's good people he's person of 2018.
yeah good question
team star's got to be up there for me
he's uh he's really changed the
community yeah he's one of my mates the
community
yeah
mine's dead G is it yeah I think he's
done well for himself at the center of
everything yeah and he's really played
the character well yeah
upset KSI but I've never understood deji
like he always seems to be he seems to
say the wrong thing but I feel like I
feel like JJ watches him and goes the
thing is
I can't agree with that because when I
went to the first uh Sideburn party I
ever went to everybody ignored me but
Daddy was the only person who came up to
me so that's right
then she knows how to pick the victims
don't look a bit better everybody else
pretended I didn't exist but Daddy count
to me and hugs me so I was like I'm
sorry
I look good next to you to be fair
though was always very friendly whether
he knew who you were it was nice to me I
thought that this this old biffing was
going to calm down I was like all right
that's it it's over and done with then
she wrote a reaction all right Stephen
job
some sloppy toppy going on there wasn't
it
how are they gonna edit this is a good
let's just say it I'm [__] happy we
didn't do this for X all because half of
it would be gone
um just a minute
the wonderful brand Xbox
latest video he did a reaction to ksi's
uh music video and I was like all right
it's calmed down now this he's probably
going to turn it around and be like oh
it's all over and not he just opens up
with about two three minutes a slate and
Randolph and you're like no this isn't
fake like not in his head whatever
whatever the reason when I realized like
I saw obviously I took a picture suit
originally but you take a lot of things
with the pinch of salt what's your
sodium level make
[Music]
I watched it the first time I was like
if JJ doesn't respond when it has to be
real yeah and that was really do you
have any kind of beef with veggie then
or not because obviously you had all
those podcasts come out not the deji one
so I didn't ever speak to you about this
but from an outsider's point of view I
thought there must be some kind of no
actually I get on well with them when I
see him in person but there was a moment
where there was a moment where so I only
was supposed to have Logan and JJ but
Jake good ones Jake came with Logan and
you thought and in your head I'm like
all right son yeah yeah all right and
then the other one yeah so that was all
and then it didn't I I messaged edgy a
while back and I was like oh if you've
got time he never replied and I was like
all right then no problem I'll just do
the these three and then they'll put
them out and that's it right you know
yeah
it was your 100th and people yeah well
pissed off that Jake Paul
some people thought just be clear in the
background maybe you should have done a
podcast with a person who helped you set
it all up the person who said yeah sure
was busy that day
for the 100th podcast
I should have brought on all the girls
you'd have spoken about on the entire
world there's only one girl he's a loyal
Ali yeah
she's the guy with him as Brian says
boys give me um an escrow Lawrence
um calendar for 2018 so thanks boys
thank you sir James Lawrence Olcott
great Channel
James Hawker organized that can I just
say July
I love it you're making my life way
easier keep going we're not an EXO
anymore my friend I think you know a lot
of you are in relationships but who is
your like
I've I went with me
anybody with more subscribers than me
technically technically keemstar is in
that uh
that really feels like that's your
question if you feel like it's not going
well I'll just bring out the whole I
love the whole place
or boyfriend would allow you to [__]
yeah if if they came along with a choice
Ariana's gaming holy which I imagine she
has given her Barbados heritage
if you are watching and you are then uh
get pondycock
you're better than that
yeah
people are being higher Steve for some
reason she's not really funny when I
first met Stephen he was this quiet he
shot a young man I've just I've just
looked what I've done look what I've
done
my girlfriend's changing the road yeah
I'll shag a honey badger at this point
oh will who's your hall pass uh Jenna
Coleman
what she's done what me has done to you
is when they know that you like a girl
they have to brainwash you and not like
her so then they have a term of an
endearment in its big round-headed [__]
that is literally exactly what Miracles
have you got a whole Pastor anyone who
you like you ultimate like your who's
your dream I've been I've been told not
to message James Charles again why
because the first message me and James
Charles River exchanges about my car
yeah so would you I've had his address
it surely he's a bit of a pretty boy is
is that what you would go for I mean
when I looked at him I was like you know
he could be female it could be male
depends on how much makeup he's got no
he generally he does look like a person
who could dress either way generally
like because his appearance is very he's
a pretty boy he could dress up as like a
woman and you wouldn't know
man I'm just more water they'll see this
and then I'll write you off right and
you'll see us you know his [__]
no James Charles uh
oh
my God
Lawrence do you have a whole place
is it jabby uh
shabby's my whole passes Alonso it was
the most I saw him in the other room and
I genuinely remember looking at him
interviewing by someone else and I
remember thinking I believe it was that
[__] should I ask you about are they I
remember thinking you know
uh I'm gonna be thinking that's gonna
peek at 45k views
you were there weren't you Stephen what
was Lauren's like what was what was what
I was like around that I was Lawrence
was also a bit nervous but that's that's
because it like he's your hero isn't it
genuinely uh a peak where I thought
I'm so glad that I hung out with these
[__] for such a long time no I'm not
good with empathy but I could see like
shabby Alonso is she's good with him I
watched it and it was a good video yeah
I just remember thinking if there was
one thing that I want to get across
today
I could say I could tell you this
actually ever since
Edison Cavani he's only ever played his
PSG
the annoying thing is if if we'd shown
the full footage idea I think we
actually held our own massively when it
was heads and volumes we were good they
did weak foot penalties to be fair
um
what about have you got a a whole person
um Jack's got Ollie white and three days
and so well what is this anyone or you
can [__] anyone as long as the Mrs would
like allow it it's actually really quite
like the one that Jake Paul used to be
with oh this is
Alyssa yeah
I'm not gonna lie she seems like a bit
of a [__]
yeah but you haven't got to worry about
that in the moment
she wasn't my type by any means but I
thought Eric was a really nice girl
that's um and apparently they've got
beef as well you know like uh
Elizabeth's being thrown shade
um Erica I don't know why it doesn't
seem natural when you get excited about
stuff like that yeah
to be honest with you the only time I'll
get excited is when I look at their
Instagrams
Brian do you have a you don't need a
whole past oh there's anyone that you
needed a whole past four aside from
my sort of my man and then then you've
got to have a home if you were with this
girl Lawrence
do you lock yourself down yeah who's
that
I don't know who that is
what most people in terms of plus size
model but she's she's oh you're I think
she's liking her a lot on Instagram
Brian will be there what yeah she's
trying to say Lawrence is trying to say
is if this belongs they just belongs to
mg would you replace him with the
podcast there's times where we'll be on
the kickoff and you know what you have a
quiet moment where nothing's really
happened on the football I'll just be
like
there were times where I look over and
we're recording something and Brian has
gone from I'll go Ryan bring up the
offers and he'll go yeah bring up the
offers
I love The Bravery that's not my
instrument yeah yeah this is but my dad
got insta about two years ago and he
just like tweets every now and then yeah
and then someone tweeted me and went you
need to get your dad off Twitter look at
his likes and I went on his likes he
just liked loads of porn videos
especially back in the day there was a
picture of your dad yesterday with you
as a young kid and I remember looking
thinking your dad was a good looking
yeah
that is the weirdest thing I thought
this is the most bisexual podcast we've
ever done it love it I always thought
I'd try it for a long time because my
sister convinced me
[Laughter]
actually weirdly uh most girls that have
been attracted to me in my life have
been bisexual because uh they always
tell me I either go for a really girly
girl or really manly man I mean look at
you I'm like oh you're already girly man
obviously 100 uh what else have you said
if you had to switch laws for any other
co-host who would you go for great
question hello Brian to be fair you do
have two other people but but it doesn't
have to be completely for example this
is good when you were selecting your
co-host I suggested yeah your girlfriend
I thought she would have been good and
that's why I didn't think it was such a
choice
yeah all right well he didn't think of a
politically as I've said as I've said I
would be a great left Winger on EXO so
you know if you ever need me
for that okay
if I had to replace Florence it would be
with a woman because I feel like um man
when that's that's why I said you and
your girlfriend because there isn't a
lot of man woman uh Partnerships on
YouTube at all that that are good in my
opinion there's a gut in the market
there and every single one that is I
just made a video on very sure
you are so off the podcast
empty all right two two very different
people
you know often think though is it it is
weird how people pair up because you we
could you could have had such a
different you could be at 2
it would be a really weird different
route if you've gone down the route of
someone who you went uh that guy matches
My Views perfectly I'll just go down
that route I I did think about that and
I thought God that would be [__]
terrible
yeah but then you two were but then I
realized how how unique I was how
original I was I thought there's no
chance of that yeah go the other way but
genuinely do you know what I thought
when I was trying to find a podcast uh a
guy to do the podcast with I only
thought of you and it was because I
thought I've done enough work for one
lifetime who's the person who makes us
feel the least like actual work actual
work and I just think [__] around
with your mate is like that's what we're
here for Lads
sales for Ollie white we'd only met once
before we did the podcast do you know
that really no so we met once when we
did this it was a difference meeting in
the beginning
so I'd met you a few times in London uh
we also did um the sidemen
um it was time in charity match the
first one when we've got banned from it
before we became
oh we did things together we'd only met
once and we met on the day I remember
taking the train to Southampton and
being like
actually the first time me and you ever
actually met was when we did the first
time we did the pilot yeah so we don't
we only texted and Brian literally we
texted each other and gone yeah it'll be
fine and that'll be fine yeah no we
literally turned upon the day and went
and then charity match was one of the
funniest even to this day I can watch
that pack and piss me some you know more
than any podcast because
because we got stuff from doing it again
I know we really pushed a few buttons
why literally how long you've made this
wait you two actually got
stuff Joe Weller and Elliot the next
year because we pissed a lot of songs
I brought it up when I was drunk go
ahead [__] drunk do you remember
when you two uh pointed out that two
people came about to you uh up during
the match yeah yeah those are my [__]
in real life mates really yes yes
when the picture Invasion happened and
they bowed no because they they don't
come on yeah leave us alone yes don't
want to meet you no that was my like
George and Kyle because they both went
to that game
they messaged me off when it's going we
got 90 smallest two Geordie and I was
like one day you know one day I will uh
that was it doesn't know that was really
[__] so technically most guys will
see this podcast the game we did it
first so it's not that impressive so
yeah
because I in my head like I've I had one
mate from back home who um
he's like Lauren's tiny bit in terms of
like just a sarcastic prick but not the
same person it's a [__] but I used to
just have such a laugh at him and then
when I met Lawrence I was like oh this
is the same like me and him just click
and then when we did the side man
charity match I was just like this is
one of the funniest things I've ever
done like this this podcast is going to
be mint we're going to have such a
[__] laugh yeah I
remember watching that and then I
remember you two of being like why the
[__] are these people wherever I'm
bowing to me I just got a Facebook
message about five minutes after going
or just bow to the tree Geordie and I
was like you guys have made yourself a
lot of complete Pricks I've never had so
many people message me and say I hope
you get cancer
he opened his DMS on the live stream and
this was when I'm not saying that mean
Lawrence are the biggest YouTubers by
any means but literally like we are well
known yeah we weren't well known then
especially Lauren's Blossom and you got
a lot of [__] that did yeah so my DMs
were open because I had I think 4 000
followers and you're a big story we were
trying to make 25 year olds laugh on a
stream full of 10 year olds so in our
heads we're like
we don't give a [__] that there's two
million people watching live as long as
we're laughing we don't we don't care we
[__] up in absolutely I think that's
what you need to do yeah I think if you
do a joke that you you deem as clever
and you think that 90 of people won't
get it when those 10 do you're like I'm
[__] yeah
I I wanted to meet up again because I
was watching the kickoff a few days ago
yes I do and I remember
Stephen does text me most weeks Stephen
talks about 10 I'm thinking myself why
don't you just come on that was a that
was a joke on the kickoff that went over
most people's heads so I very much
appreciated that was the sports
Personality of the Year joke right
because Halal ham does deserve it I've
got a question for you actually right
out of all the podcasts you've done who
has been the best
you learned a lot about them that you
didn't already know you thought they
might be a bit average and they were a
bit decent and without really cussing
anyone up who's not really telling us
I don't want to say who's the shittiest
guest but who is it I know who the [__]
is straight away no if you can't say it
tell me I think the best guess in terms
of
um I think that we've had some great
guests General I think Tony belly was
someone I really liked in terms of but
that was EXO but I still got them as
mine because I was the one who [__]
wanted to have him on yeah he was
someone who I just loved as soon as I
met I thought it was a class Blow from
shagging
um this is a lot of good sex on this
this podcast which is fun in terms of
who I didn't expect to be amazing but
really was amazing we'll show you
showing that one Sean Sean is by far one
of the most genuine people I love what
you and I have met yeah
you've gone to prison do you mean he's
been or he's gone but the story
so a quick a quick rundown if you
haven't seen it Sean Atwood was a guy
who uh built his reputation on the stock
America made a lot of money then decided
he loved drugs he was going to sell them
instead ship the Lord of ease ended up
dealing with the new Mexican Mafia got
caught selling drugs ended up in prison
for about six years and then finally got
out and now he's trying to educate kids
while you should so somebody could say
that he lived the same life as a
YouTuber does he still deal or is that
it's the Wolf of Wall Street as
England's Wolf of Wall Street is what I
call them because it's very similar sort
of story in terms of success and drugs
and all that but he was just a great
dude to do a podcast with in terms of
people who've let me down I think
there's been some podcasts which I was a
bit uh
um there was there was a there was a few
people who I was a bit disappointed with
and you should get the karaoke machine
out and do some dizzy Rascal songs
when dizzy Rascal came on the podcast I
had this image of him as the 16 year old
me who listened to the 16 17 year old
dizzy Roscoe who's a real like educated
young dude who really had his [__]
finger on the pus of how people my age
were feeling and and thinking at the
time and just felt [__] helpless I
mean yeah absolutely in the album right
he nailed it genuinely when I met him
and when we asked him certain questions
and he and he got a bit sensitive and a
bit aggressive specifically towards
Lawrence
and he had in my head I was thinking to
myself
at the time I was thinking just let it
go because he's a big name and I'm
trying to deal with that for one of the
first times in terms of having someone
from the music industry in retrospect I
wish I'd just turned around and said
um if you don't want to ask the question
answer the questions then [__] off me
you know what I mean like but I think
how much I liked him as a young person
influence how I interviewed him and
that's a learning curve for me and I
wish
if you're just gonna act like a dick
then you'll get the real me do you know
what I mean yeah I think everybody gets
that though like I every single time I
meet YouTubers who I've been watching
for 10 years no matter how many videos
I've made on them I always
how many videos
I told you videos
when you meet somebody no matter who it
is along those lines you kind of do give
them more leeway subconsciously than I
think yeah and I didn't realize that
until after I watched it back and I was
like that's not me really don't get me
wrong it wasn't like it wasn't like I
totally took me foot off the guy that
wasn't there you ask him no I thought we
ended it thinking he will know that we
are fans of him and therefore he will
give us answers which would Merit that
and there was a point in the podcast
where he went journalists and people
like you and I was like oh
yeah it's different and I remember
thinking you've completely misjos this
because actually you don't you don't
understand I'll be honest it was just a
bit of a letdown right for me and since
then it's to the point where I don't
even listen to his music anymore because
I'm just like oh yeah now then that
you've got so this podcast has always
been like a thing that you want to grow
and grow and grow yeah and now you've
hit certain like guests do you feel that
so you've had Logan on who's obviously
massive blah blah blah you might get
someone who's seen him alone now but
like um not like huge like Logan do you
feel like if you then get them on it
will then be like a step down no I don't
care I don't care about status it's
about chats so I've had people on since
then
so who seriously are um I can tell
they're here for their own interests and
that's when I'm like
and lately I haven't done a proper
podcast interview hardly at all like
because I'm just [__] sick of people
who come on and they're like guarded and
they're like I'm not going to give you
what I'm really thinking and I'm just
like well don't [__] come here
go to the [__] yeah baby say all
those other [__] who are going to
promote your [__] and give you five
minutes and not actually tell your story
and not really give you an
engagements because if you're not going
to give you a real story of me I'm not
interested what's interesting is
actually I I know that the main I can't
watch this but I know there are people
in every office that do watch the
podcast let's be honest the kids of
mainstream media are watching us but I
think a lot of people are watching and
we watch the kids and part of me is
disappointed with mainstream media like
BBC ITV all these guys because what
they've done is they've seen the formats
that we go on YouTube and they've
started to rip them off and instead of
doing something which is Sky Sports the
debate yeah all right all these kind of
things where they go instead of coming
up with some these guys got millions of
pounds we that we had nothing to rub
together when we started this podcast I
was in a bomb shelter and that's what
annoys me is these guys have got rooms
of people who go 50 Quid a deer though
where was the Japanese prisoner of Wars
yeah
I rented it from a guy who barely spoke
English he was Russian and he has five
teeth
I reckon back in the like the old school
true Geordie podcast days yeah you would
have probably loved to have someone like
knobby Solano on the podcast but now
you've had cheers I don't know if you'd
go back down to that so do you feel like
all the genres now but to go back to
someone like that you're gonna feel like
a step down even though when you first
started a big get the same way though
because actually we've discussed this a
lot between the two of us we got offered
a lot of guests and Brian gets Neighbors
um
oh that could be an interesting guy but
actually
have you Peter Crouch offered himself
right he's correct agent offered right
and the only reason he did that is
because he wants to take off us over on
happy hour
so the reason was for one reason and it
was because he was launching his own
podcast
and it was like right so let's promote
that so perhaps would have come on I'm
gone he would have gone oh well I've got
the part of I've got stories to save
from my own podcast yeah so what we want
is people are going to come on and go
I'll tell you any story anytime and
whatever you ask if you hit upon
something so for example Kieran Dyer
wasn't
um the biggest name in football uh in
his day but he was he was a big name he
was an England player but to me if I
could recreate an interview regularly it
would be the Kieran dire interview
because he gave everything he showed
emotion he practically [__] cried he
kept up in touch with us afterwards
still text us every week like he is the
realest nicest [__] block I've had on
like here in Dyer I thought he was a
total [__] it turned out to be like as
nice as any block you say is your best
podcast today is the best podcast
Standalone podcast every single episode
he's had you on to be fair this is why
they say Jack yeah that's the best
podcast
um
I would probably have like probably have
a top three because uh I wouldn't go on
them number three Jimmy Conrad oh Jimmy
conrades lovely
um sorry to assume it's gender he might
be I don't know why a woman yeah I don't
know it's really it's hard to do that
you can probably get number one can't
you what what swings the moment I say
true Johnny podcast because you probably
want to say Shira but then no Shira
wasn't the best podcast because Shira
you need people who are going to con
completely give themselves over so
what's your best friend he can't though
he's never left
I love the shirts yeah exactly yeah but
what there's a there's a wall there with
certain people that it doesn't matter
how good of an interviewer you are
you're never gonna break down and I'm
getting to the point where I'm just
[__] off with trying I'm just like
look if you turn up then just give us
what I want I think my my favorite one
as somebody who was football for a long
time and also has been subscribed to a
channel since today's what you did we
get it when you have a sexual house
[__] off Stephen my favorite I think my
favorite one was the Kieran the Karen
Dyer one that was really good see you
interview Karen dying as a Newcastle fan
oh yeah I put myself in the position
where I was like as somebody who is a
big football fan and has seen England
disappoint people time it was nice and I
went it's nice to understand how he felt
because you don't normally get that you
just kind of yeah they're they're on
cloud nine and they don't want to they
don't care anymore I'm telling you now
right when I asked Kieran about as um
well Gary speed and his kids like I'm
looking at this guy's eyes and I'm
seeing like the bloodshot I like you
could say you're the emotion and I was
like yours real as they come and like I
don't know how many months ago we did
that interview but like he just texted
me recently he keeps like he'll help me
out you know I mean he's like if you
need anyone like he's a [__] Legend
so he'll probably be up there uh maybe
Sean that word maybe Nick Yaris for the
real life stories
Sean Atwood was good I like the little
the gangster Bobby comments Bobby
Cummins was a [__] Legend Brian get
basically
it was a great bit wearing the podcast I
don't know if it's he texts me every now
and then him yeah he what's that group
messages me and he says uh he sent who's
the nut group every three months he
sends me the true Geordie podcast and I
go oh that was a good time wasn't it
Bobby indigo's best to you and your son
he texted me after the podcast and he
went um uh sorry text James who set it
up I think and he said tell Brian I
wouldn't like to have a fight with him
because he would beat me and then I'd
have to kill him
I would be
[Music]
them like like stories where people just
give you everything yeah and that is
what I'm looking for it's not about
mistakes it's not about like we've got
enough subscribers and Views it really
that's not what it's about anymore for
me I always think because I've always
watched the podcast and I always say if
you go away and you think about it for a
while that's a good podcast like if it
like the next day you're still thinking
about it and a weird one that we've not
mentioned is the geez I forget his name
that he played poker oh yeah uh Charlie
and he wore those he needed a watch
I've got him on Twitter I follow this
guy on Twitter and he asked somebody
he's like a big acid head wasn't it yeah
and that was one that really stuck in my
brain yeah yeah that was one that always
stuck in my brain yeah Charlie was
amazing because Charlie did the first
one and Brian and I were fascinated
so basically we went from having
um an autistic Gambler who was 23 years
old and worth six million pounds plus to
then he he said he had um a situation
where he would just [__] any woman that
walk basically that he wondered yeah he
was like I'm gonna have multiple
girlfriends [__] it I'm living me dream
and then next time I'm speaking I'm on
the phone he's like oh yeah calm
downwards because I can [__] use um
anyway shut up man so anyway
um and then he's like oh no I've built a
calm girl out of a life of hell with her
boyfriend she's being [__] having to
do cam Girling because I um to feed her
boyfriend or whatever she's done a
runner I'll give her a couple of grand
she's on the [__] run she then went
from America to meet him in England and
now he's not uh what is it uh poker play
anyway he's still a pork I think he's
Charlie he quit being a polygamist to be
a monogamous and so that sounds
basically he dedicates to one girl so
when you hour as well when I met her I
was like [__] hell okay straight away
what I text you was like is she really
that no for lack of a better word when
she walked in the room Brian literally
went [__] I don't think I said exactly
that come here you definitely did she
had a lovely house Brian literally went
I'd [__] her and she
had that demeanor of a girl who oh yeah
she is very forward so it was she's a
very flirty person
she's like me as a YouTuber to be fair
that's why I managed up
she was very she has this is so fake she
felt yeah yeah that was the strange side
because Brian and I and you can sort of
tell him she wants Instagram followers
she said she said she had multiple
personality disorder dude and within the
time that we had the podcast there was
one personality the whole time which
Brian and I struggled with them I
remember sitting there and thinking
is her story real or is her story fake I
remember watching it thinking that is
fake 100 that was the weird thing was
she said well when I have anxiety it
comes out so a fire alarm what comes
during that podcast
there were multiple things that I would
think
the fire alarm went off you're on a
[__] podcast with a guy that's going
to give you a lot of views that's the
moment to get anxiety there were
multiple things right I thought this
girl should have anxiety right now
because yeah I'm feeling angry yes when
the terrorist attack happens flared up a
little bit no she she should have turned
into a she should have turned into a
four-year-old at some point yeah
but but it was strange because it was a
weird experience when we were looking at
each other and I remember multiple
points where you and I looked at each
other and we were like this is so funny
do you know what it is that that was one
of the most like of all the podcasts I
remember leaving and thinking that was
mental that was that's what makes the
[__] oh dude when you've got a a
legit gambling millionaire who's a young
kid he's met this fit [__] girl he's
rescued her from our life of hell and
all of a sudden she's multiple
personality disorder and you're sitting
there like this is this is a home run I
am Joe Rogan I am Joe
who knows to say part of that Dynamic
was blatantly that they were having
a lot of sex oh and a lot of drugs as
well and a lot of and you know what it
is that was captivating me because in my
head I was like well I wish I was you
son right fair play it yeah what a life
I love them I'll text them the other day
saying you've got to teach me how to
play Pokemon on this level Ryan's so
blatantly respected that guy that it was
unbelievable
no Charlie you're a [__] Legend son
you're a king among men
oh God oh my God the point where it is
it was to the point where Shira Brian
went yeah I love you yeah this book
where Brian's looking and he goes and
that was the difference between the two
of them and that's how I wanted this to
go not the Shira one I must the Shiro
one was a bit of a um oh that was a I
mean like you know what to take will
when you grew up idolizing this guy in
in Newcastle there's there's a thing
about Alan Shira that is there's not
about anyone like there's no other place
in the world there's no other person in
the world that is quite like Alan Shiro
Newcastle and Gerald and Liverpool no
it's not the same is it the same it is
yeah no no I actually don't have an
experience like that because I lived in
Durham which is very close to Newcastle
this is a great story
I would like to tell this story
sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
can't
I lived I lived in the north shut the
[__] up again
will your phone just went off Ollie
white just sold another one of your
shirts
left at this point I lived in Durham for
a for a brief period of time and Darwin
was really [__] trying to get some
more views yeah so when I was the least
explode out of my friendship no I lived
in Dallas
[Music]
uh and obviously that's up north that's
as North as it could go I remember one
time we lived in Durham and we
accidentally got in a car and we drove
and we ended up in you know the sign
that appears that says you're in
Scotland you drive past that I don't
know how that happened well I was in I
was I was living up north I was in I
went to Nando's one day one of the first
times I ever left the house which
Nando's was it in Newcastle was it the
one in the center yes it was in the
center in the in the shopping center yes
it was I went to that one as well it's a
[__] brilliant Nando's very well and
I'm sat at Nando's I'm with I'm with my
four housemates and I see a bloke walk
into Nando's with a suit on you know you
see that happen very often in Durham uh
a guy walks into Nando's with a suit and
I'm looking at and I'm thinking I reckon
organize that man because I want to say
oh it's very late into the podcast but
I'm a Chelsea fan uh
yeah yeah
am I racist I don't know you could
decide
I I was looking at this bloke he walked
into Nando's I was thinking for some
reason I recognize that man I'm from
Bournemouth that's as far south as you
can go I'm looking at this bloke walk in
I'm like it's a Spanish it's Nando's a
Spanish restaurant London it's a Spanish
restaurant
it's a good story it's because people
are talking into their Turkey right now
somewhere just being like just [__]
get on with it yeah basically I'm
looking at this I'm looking at this
right now yeah
he's looking at this brought again I
know you're from somewhere
I'm looking at and I go do you know I
know it's a black but I can't figure out
where it is
there is Rafa Benitez of all people who
have I don't know
yeah it was one of those like Liverpool
fans can meet the players days he was a
nice guy or a big name what's it what's
your biggest insecurity people are
asking if you uh you have one
now it's when people tell me that I've
never told me no
Smiles
are a [__] statement first it's
actually I watched you play FIFA I've
watched you play FIFA World Stephen
you're [__] one kid Alex yeah I
thought you remember FIFA Channel which
did exist for a few years now my my
biggest insecurity is when people come
to me and go you've never met raffle but
it is before I go I'm sorry guys
it's definitely it's definitely you
definitely haven't met him you've just
seen him anybody got a nice and force
before he got his dinner
I'll give you another detail he got the
knife first then the [__] that's a spoon
what are you getting the spoon
you've ordered a double chicken wrap
watch it in a spoon why are you dabbing
that I'll throw you [__] dick I know
I need you to um
76 minutes you [__] idiot I feel bad
for your editor yeah
it's con this week good luck son yeah
good luck sir you're not a bad man
[Music]
biggest insecurity guy
normally The Fringe surely
you can change that the fact that
everyone has a question
without Fringe most people who have hair
like that have really dodgy hairlines is
that what this is which camera do I look
into that one all right hello everyone
mine starts way higher but it's it's
just the way I'm born you know
a high hairline and bad ears good old
lady but I'll tell you what I can check
for years
so I mean I I one of the I think one of
the things if you watch
[__] you you [__] balance not
everybody can do diss tracks on the F2
freestylers all right it comes across
his face
between these two lovebirds
that's why you've been quiet for the
last five minutes
my biggest insecurity is the fact that
I'm the I'm the person who's come on
this podcast the least amount of times
so I'm relying on you to fix it
you've
got a funny walk
but we're just being a fat [__]
Sam
wow
April to Jesus is I have little elf ears
is that really your thing your ears ears
also
um can I just say this oh my beard as
well yeah I'm unaware of how incredibly
annoying I am oh God how does it hear
that annoying at all incredibly so
you've spent a lot of time with my
girlfriend spent a lot of time with me
anyone spends a lot of time with me I
become see I I really like your company
but living with you must be hell on
Earth
does she ever wear a shirt or just go to
town on you we spent time just taking
all the frustration could anyone hear
what Stephen just said it was a point
where will went I'm gonna go and edit
videos and I thought
Stephen just said does she ever wear a
strap on and go to town on you
literally give the motion just to make
sure have you ever met him yeah better
twice right outstanding woman wait he's
talking about your own girlfriend or no
no no it's his girlfriend takes me
breath away my girlfriend's uh is the
one I love so I met Steven's girlfriend
and uh did you realize it though Brian
as we found out the other way he's
[__] tiny
I promise you have an idea three times
19.
um she is she's she's of age she seems
like a perfectly lovely uh girl adorable
the one I really got along with was your
dad oh David me and him he said he's the
he's the best Man based on the stories
you've told one you're gonna eat his ass
basically right you can you can give my
dad a rim job it'll be like an ox
wedding Alex the way the way he looked
it you you and Max it's just who does he
prefer though can we get that out there
who would he be most likely I imagine I
imagine he probably did you meet him
yeah okay he probably loves you as well
the fisherman
you son of a [__] I love it the fact
that we've got an appointment in this
podcast where Stephen Chase is calling
James Charles the rod provider for I'm
Alex Oh yes Merry Christmas
[Music]
if it's like an insecure thing you know
what I'm like to me insecurity is
something that plays on your head a lot
I'm saying you're very close to great
shape
that's the thing I would want to change
about myself but but it isn't I don't
I'm not that bothered it's like uh
but it's a lot of efforts
is it your general demeanor Shannon
Briggs
uh I I'd like to make um I'm Alex kind
of money on YouTube
genuinely he makes at least I think at
least seven times if not eight nine
times the amount of money per month
two times in my case his content takes
at least
I've heard what you make and it's
probably ten times but it's 50 times
funny videos
EXO is and we have to put that back into
the business unfortunately so
um
next year New Year's resolution stop
swearing I suppose everybody should
settle on New Year's on a New Year's
resolution I want to see Brian wear pink
in every single true Geordie podcast
because because I shouldn't look like I
wear it it works
um I'm gonna I'm gonna try the ketogenic
diet next year oh yeah
no is that meat and fat lots of meat
lots of protein fat yeah
views a month I don't know the exact
number but it varies I think this month
I had about seven million views Brian
how would you have Alex it's
like oh
definitely piss off that is a happy hour
for you isn't it two million okay so it
should it really be called Jack me a
tapioa that was a real quiz
it's really starting to become a jewel
Stephen everyone here
sorry boys
um someone on this table tried to do a
long form podcast the other day didn't
work what happened
podcast
uh just a while off you thought 2018
we've got Max we've got Tom uh Tom's
actually better than Max in the video
yeah it says lots of shambles doesn't he
bless him I love him Max is there no
it's just the funniest person I've met
Max is the reason that I ended up uh
Max is the reason for this person
outside my own apartment I woke up no no
I was I woke up covered in my own blood
that's how bad it was that's how
aggressive
give me some of that blood uh what
happened seriously how did you go no so
Matt went so I was when I met you I was
already uh [__] hammered when I was
yeah
basically I was doing I was doing some
absolute tacos at the party
especially Colombia
playing around the world much turned up
and he went Maxway
Max 10 to me
around the world especially Columbia
two guys
stand up
train maps turned up and he went oh I'm
a big guy and I've obviously turned up
an hour I hate when everybody else who
went I'm gonna do two tequila shots of
peace and he went you should join in
with me uh I don't remember how far we
got so all I remember is I woke up and I
remember this man came up between the
street this is the last remember I had
from the southern party James Charles A
Man Came watching and went back
oh wait your palette all over the place
no let me fix it oh he probably could
have tried to have sex I mean I would
have agreed but actually what happened
was he went he went you're covered in
your own blood do you want to go to
hospital when I went I live over there
[Laughter]
the first time I met Max he um he had a
really long um big black coat on oh my
God they're fake tanning Stephen are we
gonna say big black sign out the thing
is actually rubbing fake what is that
from Max thought that Brian hated him
yeah
it was like Max over thinks everything
he was like
I think Brian hates because I'm annoying
it's like no no Brian Brian
will did it and then I did it on my
first time
bearing it's summer and he's wearing a
huge overcoat and I'm looking at him
like I'm I'm hot I'm a big guy you're a
big guy you you must be sweating and he
opens it he goes not to worry opens his
coat and he has like stores of deodorant
like full huge canisters of deodorant
just uh just to give it this underarm
sprayer as he goes just it was amazing I
remember you looking at me and going
[__] yeah the thing is what a guy the
best thing about that now uh he got on
the coast
no it's fine Brian he got on the couch
and apparently sir she was flirting with
him but I think I think Max is the first
person on YouTube to never flirt back
no no no
no oh Michael Smith shut up she's a
legend and max they're both the best I
would [__] them I don't want to
interactive personality is there a
toilet here because I really need it
downstairs yeah are you ready for True
Geordie problems oh we're starting again
we're gonna give some advice to the
people James Charles loves to be honest
these will all be fresh problems as well
they'll be that because I put this out
last night so they'll be there'll be
real issues that we need to tackle a lot
of issues if it's all about tanning I
don't need that got it sorted got it lit
this one's called I am awkward and I
hate it I'll take this yeah no hey there
I'm 16 years old and from Germany
my problem is that I'm always super
awkward around girls I like but it's
really easy for me to talk to my friends
or classmates male or female I never
know what to say and I get really
nervous that's why I don't really talk
to girls I'd like to date
it's a very easy problem yeah same old
say I'm older it's a
it's each old problem
so if I was if I was Jack I'd invite an
11 year old into my house fantastic wow
that's so bad he's throwing you under
the bus he's your podcast [__]
partner it's supposed to make you look
good a million you can't yeah
that was all the charity tweets from all
the big YouTubers going let's get him to
a million just in case he blows up I'm
gonna tweet this so I can go back and
Bank it later
uh what is he 16 he's 16. he wants to be
able to talk with girls hey I was
[__] pathetic till 22 so yeah you're
21 now yeah
I'm preempting this coolness
I'll take it Jack will do my answer is
in a verbal way
not literally will don't get jealous
when he goes on ubereats he just looks
for Steven's bum
yummy yummy yeah I don't talk about
eating ass sorry we've been in front of
girls no the thing is though when you've
got to talk to women you just kill me
you just need to uh not put pressure on
yourself mate not not think to myself
all right I'm trying to [__] you now
nothing about all of that just think
let's be friends if if you're gonna buy
them a drink as well make sure they take
card otherwise she's gonna run up the
High Street
place where when you go on a first date
is there a specific place that you take
someone uh never the cinema
mini golf balls are pretty good what's
that mini golf balls are pretty good
because you can drink and then beat them
insert your dominance
what are you into
and then embrace it so what sort of
thing would they say what sort of thing
if he's into Pokemon just
Stephen my thing is get them drunk oh
will you dropped your Porsche Carrington
yeah that's embarrassing whoops just for
the conversation or conversation flows
better when you've got a little bit of
confidence alcohol gives you that we
call this confidence get them drunk
liquid confidence let's take out the
sentence get them drunk let's take that
sentence
you've recognized me
and they'll fill you yeah and I always
go I can't get over how orange the palms
of Stephen's hands are [__] me Jesus
I tag quickly these lights do something
to me
who's gonna be more wrecked Stephen or
Alex Alice took it like a [__] jump
yeah
[__] Steve Austin here in the corner
Paul Gasco tries 316. I've got a
semi-final in 10 minutes Stephen Stephen
can I just say you're my favorite person
of 2018 I'm gonna revise that [__]
yourself
cheers let's move on next problem
Dosa next problem in the question uh
I've been dating this girl for three
months now I'm wondering when I should
pop the question no not the marriage
question
mark no not the marriage question the
want to have sex question
that's not what people go what will I
say is
to be fair 11 year olds do it usually
that's it right he's come on quick and
if she doesn't say yes then
frigid little girl get in the bed I'll
find another year 11. no that's where we
crossed that that's right that's where
we go too far
we mean prison sentence
the problem is is this is a ship that
always gets edited out finally we can
leave it in yeah Merry Christmas how old
are these people I know we're joking
this person's
I'm looking forward to Brian's advice
due to the fact that he's managed to get
women in bed within minutes obviously
consensus brackets
I do like how they've added in obviously
consent because most YouTubers they
don't need that yeah that's true we're
not all your mates Alex calm down
thanks in advance uh if this gets red it
does hope you have a good Christmas New
Year yeah it depends you've got to judge
the girl haven't you but you have to
basically get to know what they want
before you meet up with them and make
sure that you're like when you're
messaging that you're on the same page
yeah so that you're not Crossways
because if you are Crossways that can
come across the wrong wage I mean she
might not like that you can never go
wrong if you if you how do you ask her
to [__] you after three months
20 minutes what are we talking about I
actually [__] have a clue he wants to
[__] this girl he's been dating her for
three months well you just neck on with
her and then oh one thing and he said
they don't that's it what leads to what
though does the hands go somewhere yeah
how old are you when you lost your v
plates uh
there we go 18
18. I'm disclosed yeah
what is it come on Stephen no are you
[__] 16. yours and I'll admit I wasn't
I wasn't I shouldn't have done it then
I wanna I wanna know why you shouldn't
have done it just wasn't ready you know
what I mean I'm sitting there like a
[__] [__] with training wheels on
just trying to navigate the skills no
but like in my head I think let me
subtle I remember just my mind was blown
by the whole experience
what no no no I remember
this is an honest account of one of the
worst bits about losing your virginity
if you're like 8701 it was a classic
album but do you know when you leave a
song on repeat yeah this is how bad it
was for her
not for you you were having a great time
no I wasn't having a great time so I had
a condom on I could barely [__] feel
a thing but anyway
there was a point where she turned she
turned to me and she goes
fisting each other can we put the next
song
she asked me to put the next song on
where were you having sex it was in the
club he went DJ next song DJ spin that
[__] DJ if Brian went yeah absolutely
baby no it was okay next one it wasn't
good
um so I do I do um I think I should have
the thing is you just when you're 16 you
just want to get it done I mean you're
not bothered learning what a woman wants
you're not learning about what she likes
having a good time you're just wanting
to [__] get it in get it done and
that's what I was like and I wish I'd
been a bit more like all right how does
this thing actually work
sorry
I mean he's not completely wrong do you
reckon I would just want to say one
thing about this podcast it's Christmas
Day oh yeah Christmas do you reckon you
reckon do you reckon for Christmas Son
speaks about nonsense it's Christmas do
you reckon we're getting ads on this
podcast
yeah this is about the people all right
I'll tell you what oh god my virginity
was sadly lost uh how old how old were
you oh Brian I'll be honest you're prick
don't do that be honest this year I'm
not gonna lie I was a sad wet wipe okay
uh Anna with put on a song it was a DJ
set DJ Cami All I Ever Wanted
just instantly if I heard that
it was a 90 minute set and we got
through the whole thing anyway this
hasn't gone well has it
fair play
not a stallion just a dodgy [__]
Andaman
that's why though what is that your
girlfriend now yeah
do you know it is she's watching you so
I'm dying no but the thing is part of
getting better is realizing how [__] you
are yeah we all have to have that moment
nobody starts off a stallion nobody
starts off a stallions I wanna I wanna
fish you mate thanks we had very similar
experiences yep
right that makes sense I mean that's
fine that's right no it's not
no one said it
says
for the day beyond the year of 17 I was
like oh this is pathetic no but each day
I'd wake up and go no
there's a big difference right Stephen
you're a YouTuber so it's all right if
you're a [__] weirdo that's it that's
fine
eventually it's okay though I get views
sometimes have you seen how to be
stormzy there it is
in winter
okay
it never happened
this is where we
end Merry Christmas you've done really
well thank you very much
finally I cried enjoy yourself Vesuvius
has erupted enjoy your past very good
and I want to say I'm not supposed to
have been dribbles
you've been watching The Chosen Woody
podcast merry Christmas everybody
Christmas 2018. I hope you've had a good
time enjoy your Sprouts I'll see you
soon